In a slightly less dire example,...
...satirical articles that are formatted to resemble real ones...
...can also be picked up by outlets not in on the joke.
For example, a joke article in the reputable British Medical Journal...
...entitled "Energy Expenditure in Adolescents...
...Playing New Generation Computer Games,"...
...has been referenced in serious science publications over 400 times.
User-generated content such as wikis...
...are also a common contributor to circular reporting.
As more writers come to rely on such pages for quick information,...
...an unverified fact in a wiki page...
...can make its way into a published article...
...that may later be added as a citation...
...for the very same wiki information,...
...making it much harder to debunk.
Recent advances in communication technology...
...have had immeasurable benefits...
...in breaking down the barriers between information and people,...
...but our desire for quick answers...
...may overpower the desire to be certain of their validity...
...and when this bias can be multiplied by billions of people around the world...
...nearly instantaneously, more caution is in order.
Avoiding sensationalist media...
...searching for criticisms of suspicious information,...
...and tracing the original source of a report can help slow down a lie,...
...giving the truth more time to put on its shoes.